♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
HAVE YOU EVER NOTICED HOW NOBODY
IN WASHINGTON CAN AGREE ON A
NUMBER?
MATH IS SUPPOSED TO BE
OBJECTIVE, EXCEPT IN OREGON
WHERE IT IS RACIST, BUT IN THE
REAL WORLD YOU WOULD THINK
PEOPLE ARE FUNCTIONING
CALCULATORS COULD COME TO
SIMILAR MATH-BASED CONCLUSIONS
ONCE IN A WHILE.
BUT NOT IN D.C.
TRY GETTING A CONSENSUS ON
UNEMPLOYMENT PROJECTIONS OR
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE LEVELS FOR
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
YOU CAN’T EVEN GET A STRAIGHT
ANSWER ON HOW MANY TROOPS WILL
BE OCCUPYING THE CAPITAL THREE
MONTHS FROM NOW, AND I DO
SOMETHING THEY DIRECTLY CONTROL.
EVEN ALLOWING FOR THE FACT THAT
MOST POLITICIANS AREN’T CAPABLE
OF MATH, IT IS STRIKING.
STATISTICS TURN OUT TO BE A LOT
SLIPPERY OR THAN THEY LOOK.
SO WITH ALL OF THAT IN MIND,
IT’S PRETTY AMAZING TO WATCH
VIRTUALLY EVERYONE IN
WASHINGTON, REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS, REPEAT PRECISELY THE
SAME NUMBER ON ONE OF THE MOST
CRITICAL PROBLEMS THAT WE FACE,
AND THAT NUMBER IS 11 MILLION.
THAT NUMBER, THEY TELL US, IS
EXACTLY HOW MANY FOREIGN
NATIONALS CURRENTLY LIVE HERE
ILLEGALLY.
ALL THE EXPERTS SAY THAT.
THERE ARE PRECISELY 11 MILLION
UNDOCUMENTED ALIENS.
NOW, 11 MILLION IS A LOT.
ON THE OTHER HAND, AT A TIME OF
TRILLION DOLLAR SPENDING BILLS,
IS IT REALLY SO MANY?
11 MILLION ISN’T WHAT IT USED TO
BE.
IN ANY CASE, THAT IS EXACTLY HOW
MANY ILLEGAL ALIENS THERE ARE
PURELY 11 MILLION.
11 MILLION.
NO MORE, NO LESS.
>> 250 MILLION UNDOCUMENTED
PEOPLE IN THE WORLD TODAY, THE
UNITED STATES HAS 11 MILLION.
>> THE 11 MILLION UNDOCUMENTED.
>> 11 MILLION PEOPLE WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
IS THAT WHAT WE WANT TO DO?
>> NO, --
>> 11 MILLION UNDOCUMENTED
PEOPLE --
>> OH COME ON 11 MILLION --
>> THIS IS AMERICA, WE ARE NOT
GOING TO ROUND UP 11 MILLION
PEOPLE.
>> HAS REMAIN STABLE AT
11 MILLION FOR HALF A DECADE.
>> NEGATIVE IMPACT 11 MILLION
PEOPLE.
HIM >> AS UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANT, 1 OF 11000000 WHO ARE
VIEWED AS CRIMINALS.
WE WANT IT IS ALL MOST LIKE A
SCRIPT.
PEOPLE HAVE DIFFERENT VIEWS ON
WHAT WE OUGHT TO DO ABOUT
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, BUT NOBODY
QUESTIONS HOW MANY THERE ARE,
BECAUSE THERE ARE 11 MILLION,
PERIOD.
JOE BIDEN KNOWS THIS.
WE CHECKED WITH THE DOCTOR HE
LIVES WITH, DR. JILL BIDEN IS
NOT A PRACTICING PHYSICIAN, WE
ESTABLISH THAT AFTER DOING A
LITTLE REPORTING WITH OUR
SOURCES IN THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY, BUT DR. JILL IS NOTED
AS AN REGARDED ACADEMIC
RESEARCHER WHO DID A RESEARCH
PIECE IN DELAWARE, SO SHE KNOWS
PRECISELY HOW MANY UNDOCUMENTED
FUTURE AMERICANS LIVE HERE.
IT’S 11 MILLION.
SHE PASSED ON HER NEWS TO JOE.
>> WITHIN A HUNDRED DAYS, I’M
GOING TO SEND TO THE
UNITED STATES CONGRESS A PATHWAY
TO CITIZENSHIP FOR OVER
11 MILLION UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE,
AND ALL OF THOSE SO-CALLED
DREAMERS, THOSE OF THE ACA KIDS,
THEY ARE GOING TO BE IMMEDIATELY
CERTIFIED AGAIN TO BE ABLE TO
STAY IN THIS COUNTRY AND PUT ON
A PASS TO CITIZENSHIP.
>> Tucker: THAT TAPE WAS SHOT
ONE MONTH BEFORE THE NOVEMBER
ELECTION, HE PROMISED TO TURN
11 MILLION UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE,
DREAMERS, PEOPLE WITH BIG DREAMS
COME INTO AMERICAN CITIZENS BY
GIVING THEM AMNESTY.
NOT LONG AFTER THAT BY GIVING
THEIR ABSENTEE BALLOTS.
IT WAS A BIG PROMISE, BUT
JOE BIDEN IS IN THE WHITE HOUSE,
SO HE CAN MAKE GOOD ON THAT
PROMISE, AND HE PLANS TO DO SO.
IN FACT, IT WAS ONE OF THE VERY
FIRST THINGS HE IS DOING.
HOW IS IT GOING TO AFFECT YOU?
WELL COME ACCORDING TO
JOE BIDEN’S -- IT MEANS YOU WILL
HAVE EXACTLY 11 MILLION NEW
FELLOW AMERICANS.
>> CERTAINLY IS PART OF THE
PROPOSAL THAT THE PRESIDENT
OUTLINED AND PROPOSED ON DAY ONE
IS AN EARNED PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP, RIGHT, 411 MILLION
IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS LIVING
IN THE COUNTRY.
>> AN EARNED PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP.
NO BIG DEAL.
THEY EARNED IT.
EVERY BIT OF IT.
PRESUMABLY BY MARKING THE LAWS
OF THE COUNTRY THEY WILL NOT
HAVE A ROLE IN RUNNING.
ACTUALLY, IT IS KIND OF A BIG
DEAL.
ADDING 11 MILLION NEW CITIZENS
WOULD HAVE BIG EFFECTS ON
AMERICA, PROFOUND EFFECTS.
HOW MANY PEOPLE IS 11 MILLION
PEOPLE?
WELL, 43 OF THE 50 U.S. STATES
HAVE A SMALLER POPULATION THAT
11 MILLION.
NOT JUST WYOMING AND
SOUTH DAKOTA, IT’S VIRGINIA,
GEORGIA, MICHIGAN, NEW JERSEY,
MASSACHUSETTS, AND SO ON, BIG
STATES.
WHAT WOULD THIS COST?
NO ONE ASKS.
IT’S KIND OF HARD TO KNOW THE
REAL ANSWER.
BUT IF YOU’RE TRYING TO PUT THE
MATH TOGETHER, BE SURE TO FACTOR
IN THE FREE HEALTH CARE YOU WILL
SOON BE PAYING FOR EVERY ONE OF
THE 11 MILLION.
>> DO YOU SUPPORT GIVING
UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE, MEDICARE
FOR ALL, TO PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY?
>> LET ME BE VERY CLEAR ABOUT
THIS.
I AM OPPOSED TO ANY POLICY THAT
WOULD DENY IN OUR COUNTRY ANY
HUMAN BEING FROM ACCESS TO
PUBLIC SAFETY, PUBLIC EDUCATION,
OR PUBLIC HEALTH, PERIOD.
>> Tucker: NOW IT DOES NOT
TAKE AN ECONOMIST TO KNOW THAT
GIVING FREE "HEALTH CARE," WHICH
OBVIOUSLY WILL INCLUDE GENDER
TRANSITION, BY THE WAY, TO
11 MILLION NEW PEOPLE COULD
EASILY CAPSIZE THE ENTIRE U.S.
ECONOMY, VERY EASILY.
AS MILTON FRIEDMAN ONCE WISELY
NOTED, YOU CAN HAVE A WELFARE
STATE OR YOU CAN HAVE OPEN
BORDERS, BUT YOU CANNOT HAVE
BOTH.
YEAH, WE ARE GETTING BOTH.
BUT WE MAY, IN FACT, BE GETTING
A GREAT DEAL MORE THAN THAT, AND
THAT IS THE PURPOSE OF THE
SEGMENT TONIGHT.
WE ALL ASSUME THAT 11 MILLION IS
THE REAL NUMBER.
BUT IS IT THE REAL NUMBER?
IS THAT ACTUALLY THE NUMBER OF
FOREIGN NATIONALS WHO LIVE
WITHIN OUR BORDERS ILLEGALLY AND
WILL BE GETTING AMNESTY VERY
SOON?
NO, IT’S NOT THE REAL NUMBER.
IN FACT, IT IS A TOTALLY FAKE
NUMBER.
WHICH PEOPLE ENDLESSLY REPEAT
ONLY BECAUSE THEY ARE BADLY
INFORMED OR DISHONEST.
THEY’VE BEEN REPEATING THAT
NUMBER FOR A VERY LONG TIME,
MORE THAN 15 YEARS, AT LEAST.
WAY BACK IN 2005, THE PEW
RESEARCH CENTER ANNOUNCED THAT
"THE UNDOCUMENTED POPULATION HAS
REACHED NEARLY 11 MILLION."
THTHE REAR THING IS THAT 12 YEAR
LATER, PUGH HAD ROUGHLY THE SAME
ESTIMATE.
NOTHING HAD CHANGED IN MORE THAN
A DECADE, AND THAT SHOULD HAVE
ANY TELL THAT THE NUMBER ITSELF
WAS FRAUDULENT.
IN 2018, THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY, WHICH EXISTS
TO TRACK NUMBERS LIKE THESE,
PLAYED ALONG WITH IT AND PUT THE
NUMBER OF ILLEGAL ALIENS IN THE
U.S. SOMEWHERE AROUND
12 MILLION.
RIGHT.
THEY JUST MADE THAT UP.
WATCH OUR INTERVIEW FROM APRIL
APRIL 2019 WITH THE THEN HEAD OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY, KRISTEN NIELSEN.
WHEN PUSHED, NIELSEN CONCEDED
THAT ACTUAL, SHE DIDN’T KNOW THE
REAL NUMBER.
SHE HAD NO IDEA.
>> DOES THE U.S. GOVERNMENT KNOW
EXACTLY HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
LIVING IN THIS COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY?
I HAVE SEEN ACADEMICS PUT THAT
NUMBER BETWEEN 11 MILLION,
22 MILLION, MAY BE MORE.
WHAT IS THE REAL NUMBER?
>> WE DEBATED.
>> SO WE DON’T NOT KNOW?
>> WE DO NOT KNOW, NO.
>> THAT MUST BE OF GREAT CONCERN
TO YOU THAT WE POTENTIALLY MORE
THAN 10 MILLION PEOPLE HERE
WHOSE IDENTITIES WE DON’T KNOW,
COULD BE OVER 20, WHOSE IDENTITY
WE DON’T KNOW, AND THEY COULD BE
ANYBODY.
>> YES.
>> AND SO WHY IS THAT NOT THE
SINGLE MOST PRESSING PROBLEM
McCARTY HAS?
>> IN MY OPINION, RIGHT NOW,
THIS IS ONE OF IF NOT THE
BIGGEST CRISIS THIS COUNTRY HAS
FACED IN A DECADE.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
SO, WE DON’T KNOW.
THE QUESTION IS, WHAT IS THE
REAL NUMBER?
AND WHY IS EVERYONE SAYING IT IS
11 MILLION?
WHY IS EVERYONE COMING TO THE
SAME WRONG CONCLUSION.
THEY ARE NOT ALL LYING.
SO WE CHECKED, AND HERE’S WHAT
WE FOUND.
PRETTY MUCH EVERYBODY WHO TALKS
ABOUT IMMIGRATION, INCLUDING
DR. JILL BIDEN, IS USING THE
CENSUS BUREAU ANNUAL AMERICAN
COMMUNITY SURVEY TO ESTIMATE HOW
MANY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ARE IN
THIS COUNTRY.
ONE SENIOR LECTURER AT MIT PUT
IT THIS WAY: IT HAS BEEN THE
ONLY METHOD USED FOR THE LAST
THREE DECADES.
SO WHAT IS THE METHOD?
WELL, THE CENSUS TALLIES UP THE
NUMBER OF FOREIGN-BORN PEOPLE
THEY HAVE IDENTIFIED WHO LIVE IN
THIS COUNTRY.
THEN ESTIMATORS SUBTRACT THE
NUMBER OF FOREIGN-BORN PEOPLE
KNOWN TO BE IN THE U.S.
ILLEGALLY.
BINGO.
11 MILLION.
THAT’S WHAT YOU GET.
THE PROBLEM IS, THIS METHOD OF
CALCULATION IS FOUND TO BE
WRONG.
MANY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS DON’T
RESPOND TO CENSUS TAKERS.
WHY WOULD THEY?
THEY ARE HERE ILLEGALLY.
ROBERT GROVE IS THE FORMER
DIRECTOR OF THE CENSUS BUREAU,
AND SUMMED UP THE LEGALITY THIS
WAY, "THERE IS NO MAGIC BULLET
THAT ANYONE HAS DISCOVERED TO
COMPASS POPULATION.
THIS IS REALLY VERY DIFFICULT TO
ESTIMATE."
OH.
SO MANY OF THE STUDIES PROJECT
THEY’RE ONLY 11 MILLION ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS HAVE COME IN FACT,
ACKNOWLEDGED THE CENSUS IS NOT
PERFECT.
THEY HAVE BEEN HONEST ABOUT
THAT.
BUT STRANGELY, THEY ASSUME IT
WAS PRETTY CLOSE TO PERFECT.
SPECIFICALLY, THEY OPERATE ON
THE ASSUMPTION THAT ONLY ABOUT
10% OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
WEREN’T BEING CAPTURED BY CENSUS
TAKERS, WEREN’T RESPONDING TO
THE FORMS.
PUT ANOTHER WAY, THEIR MODELS
ASSUME THAT 90% OF THE PEOPLE
LIVING IN THIS COUNTRY ILLEGALLY
WERE WILLING TO COOPERATE WITH
CENSUS TAKERS.
NOW WHY WOULD THEY ASSUME THAT?
THAT SEEMS LIKE A RIDICULOUS
ASSUMPTION.
BUT THERE IS A REASON.
ANN COULTER EXPLAINS THAT REASON
IN HER BOOK, "ADIOS AMERICA,
WHICH IS ONE OF THE FEW
SERIOUS EXPIRATIONS, ASSUMING IT
IS NOT BANNED BY AMAZON, WHICH
IT MIGHT BE.
THEY WERE LYING ON A STUDY 20
YEARS AGO FUNDED BY THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT SURVEY SURVEYED A TOTAL OF
829 PEOPLE BORN IN MEXICO AND
LIVING IN LOS ANGELES.
IT ASKED THEM WHETHER THEY
RESPONDED TO CENSUS INTERVIEWS.
THE MAJORITY OF THEM SAID YESES.
BUT HERE’S THE AMAZING THING,
NEARLY 40% OF THOSE HOUSEHOLDS
REFUSED TO ANSWER THE SURVEY, AT
ALL.
IN OTHER WORDS, ALL THE
ASSUMPTIONS, THAT THERE ARE
11 MILLION ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IN
THIS COUNTRY, ARE BASED ON A
SEPARATE ASSUMPTION, WHICH IS
THAT 90% OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
ARE WILLING TO COOPERATE WITH
THE CENSUS BUREAU, AND THAT
ASSUMPTION ITSELF IS BASED ON A
SURVEY SHOWING NEARLY HALF OF
ALL ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS REFUSE TO
FILL OUT THE SURVEY.
THIS IS BAD MATH, AT THE VERY
LEAST.
IN 2018, RESEARCHERS AT YALE AND
MIT DECIDED TO UPDATE THE
METHODOLOGY.
YEAH, NOT A MINUTE TOO SOON.
THEY DID NOT RELY ON CENSUS
DATA.
INSTEAD, THEY USED "OPERATIONAL
DATA," SUCH AS DEPORTATION, VISA
OVERSTATES, DEMOGRAPHIC DATA,
DEATH RATES, IMMIGRATION RATES,
ET CETERA.
THOSE ARE REAL NUMBERS.
THEY COMBINED THEM AND USED
MATHEMATICAL MODELS TO O ESTABLI
A RANGE OF ESTIMATES, HOW MANY
PEOPLE HERE LEGALLY.
HERE’S WHAT THEY FOUND, "AFTER
RUNNING 1 MILLION SIMULATIONS OF
THE MODEL, THE RESEARCHERS 95%
PROBABILITY RANGE IS 16 MILLION
TO 29 MILLION ILLEGAL ALIENS,
WITH 22.1 MILLION AS THE MEAN."
IN OTHER WORDS, THE ESTIMATE
THAT WE HAVE BEEN RELYING ON FOR
DECADES AND REPEATING TO EACH
OTHER LIKE THEY ARE REAL, THE
ESTIMATE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS NOW USING TO
JUSTIFY MASS AMNESTY, COULD
POSSIBLY IN FACT MAY LIKELY BE
OFF BY MORE THAN 18 MILLION
PEOPLE.
THERE COULD EASILY BE 30 MILLION
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS LIVING IN
THIS COUNTRY, OR MORE.
HOW MANY PEOPLE IS THAT?
THAT IS MORE PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN
THE ENTIRE STATE OF TEXAS.
SO HOW WOULD AMNESTY FOR THAT
MANY PEOPLE AFFECT OUR
"DEMOCRACY?"
THE ONE WE ARE ALSO WORRIED
ABOUT?
IN EFFECT, IT WOULD END OUR
DEMOCRACY.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE LIVED HERE ALL
OF THEIR LIVES, PAID TAXES,
FOLLOW THE RULES, GOOD CITIZENS,
WOULD FIND THEIR VOTES DILUTED
TO THE POINT OF IRRELEVANCE.
BY THE WAY, AND INSTANTANEOUS
END TO AFRICAN-AMERICAN
POLITICAL POWER, THAT WILL BE
OVER FOR GOOD, NO QUESTION ABOUT
IT.
APPARENTLY MAXINE WATERS IS TOO
DUMB TO KNOW IT, BUT I WOULD BE
EFFECTIVE.
COURSE, IT WOULD ALSO ENSURE
PERMIT WILL BY THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, WHICH IS THE
POINT OF IT.
WE SHOULD TELL YOU THAT IT IS
NOT JUST YALE AND MIT INCLUDING
THE 11 MILLION NUMBER IS
RIDICULOUS.
BACK IN 2005, BEAR STEARNS, THE
BANK COME OF ALL PLACES, REACH
THE SAME CONCLUSION.
BEAR STEARNS ESTIMATE OF THE
TOTAL ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
POPULATION TO BE AS HIGH AS
20 MILLION, THAT WAS 16 YEARS
AGO.
HERE IS THEIR TOP LINE FIGHTING
IN THAT STUDY, "OUR RESEARCH HAS
IDENTIFIED SIGNIFICANT EVIDENCE
THAT THE CENSUS ESTIMATES OF
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS MAY BE
CAPTURING AS LITTLE AS HALF OF
THE TOTAL UNDOCUMENTED
POPULATION.
THIS GROSS UNDERCOUNTING IS A
SERIOUS ACCOUNTING ISSUE WHICH
COULD ULTIMATELY LEAD TO
GOVERNMENT POLICY ERRORS IN THE
FUTURE."
OH, YOU THINK?
LIKE GIVING AMNESTY TO
11 MILLION WHO ARE ACTUALLY
30 MILLION?
YEAH, THAT COULD BE AN ERROR.
TO MAKE THIS CALCULATION, BEAR
STEARNS DID NOT RELY ON CENSUS
DATA BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT A
BANK, THEY ARE NOT AS DUMB AS
OUR GOVERNMENT.
INSTEAD, THEY LOOKED AT BANK
TRANSFERS, REMITTANCES, FROM THE
U.S. TO MEXICO, HE WANTED TO
CAPTURE THE NUMBER OF PAYMENTS
FROM ILLEGAL ALIENS LIVING HERE
TO THEIR FAMILIES BACK HOME, AND
HERE’S WHAT FOUND.
"THE RATE OF INCREASE IN
REMITTANCE FAR EXCEEDS THE RATE
OF MEXICANS RESIDING IN THE U.S.
AND WAGE GROWTH.
BETWEEN 1995 AND 2003, THE
OFFICIAL TALLIES OF MEXICAN
CLIMBED TO 56%, MEDIAN WEEKLY
WAGE INCOME INCREASED BY 10%.
YET TOTAL REMITTANCES JUMPED
199% OVER THE SAME PERIOD."
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
WELL, THERE WAS NO OBVIOUS
EXPLANATION FOR THIS DISPARITY,
PART FROM A LOT MORE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION THAN THE AUTHORITIES
WERE ACKNOWLEDGING.
AND THEN RESEARCHERS AT
BEAR STEARNS LOOKED AT OTHER
INDICATORS.
FOR EXAMPLE, THEY LOOKED AT DATA
OF SCHOOL ENROLLMENT AND HOUSING
PERMIT APPLICATIONS FOR MULTIPLE
DWELLINGS.
IN ONE INSTANCE, THEY FOUND SOME
TOWNS IN NEW JERSEY REPORTED A
FIVE OR 6% GROWTH IN POPULATION
SIZE.
AT THE VERY SAME TIME, THAT
REQUEST FOR HOUSING PERMITS
INCREASED BY 600%.
WHAT?
"IN MAJOR IMMIGRANT GATEWAY
CITIES, THE INFLUX OF IMMIGRANTS
HAS LED TO OVERCROWDED DWELLINGS
AND A HOUSING BOOM, UNEXPLAINED
BY OFFICIAL POPULATION GROWTH."
HAPPENING ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY
ARE AUTHORITIES DON’T KNOW OR
INTENTIONALLY IGNORE IT, OR
THEY LIE TO US ABOUT IT.
AGAIN, THAT WAS 16 YEARS AGO.
AND NOW, IN 2021, THE PARTY IN
CHARGE IS STILL ASSURING US THE
NUMBER OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IN
THIS COUNTRY HAS SOMEHOW
DECLINED BY UP TO 10 MILLION
PEOPLE.
COULD THAT BE TRUE?
HOW INSULTING IS THAT, EVEN
TO -- EVEN TO FLIP THAT IDEA?
CONSIDER EVERYTHING THAT HAS
HAPPENED SINCE 2006.
AMNESTY FOR THE SO-CALLED
STREAMERS, THE PROMISES OF MASS
AMNESTY, THE ENDLESS CARAVANS.
SO THE 11 MILLION NUMBER IS
ABOVE ALL, A LIE.
THE 11 MILLION NUMBER IS ONE OF
THE MORE OBVIOUS LIES EVER TOLD.
WE ARE A TV SHOW.
WE ARE NOT SOCIAL SCIENTISTS.
AND IT TOOK ABOUT AN HOUR TO
FIND THIS OUT.
IT’S A RIDICULOUS LIVE.
ON SOME LEVEL, JOE BIDEN KNOWS
THIS.
IN THE SUMMER OF 2019, HE MORE
OR LESS ADMITTED IT.
THE POINT OF AMNESTY, HE
SUGGESTED, IS NOT JUST TO GIVE
CITIZENSHIP TO 11 MILLION
PEOPLE.
THE POINT IS TO IMPORT AS MANY
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS AS POSSIBLE,
AND THERE IS NO LIMIT.
WATCH.
>> WE COULD AFFORD TO TAKE, IN A
HEARTBEAT, ANOTHER 2 MILLION
PEOPLE.
THE IDEA THAT A COUNTRY OF
330 MILLION PEOPLE CANNOT ABSORB
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN DESPERATE NEED
AND WHO ARE JUSTIFIABLY FLEEING
OPPRESSION IS ABSOLUTELY
BIZARRE.
ABSOLUTELY BIZARRE.
I WOULD ALSO MOVE TO INCREASE
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF IMMIGRANTS
ABLE TO COME TO THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Tucker: HE’S JUST THROWING
NUMBERS OUT THERE.
THEY ALL ARE.
THEY DON’T KNOW THE REAL NUMBER.
THEY ARE HIDING WHAT THEY DO
KNOW.
THEIR CLOAKING THE OBVIOUS.
I NEED MORE SLOGANS.
CONSIDER HOW UNBELIEVABLY
IRRESPONSIBLE IT IS FOR A
POLICYMAKER -- NOT
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES -- TO THROW OUT
THERE, YEAH, WE WILL COVER FREE
HEALTH CARE FOR EVERYONE HERE
ILLEGALLY, WITHOUT EVEN KNOWING
HOW MANY PEOPLE THAT IS.
THAT IS INSANE.
WHO WOULD DO SOMETHING LIKE
THAT?
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THE
COUNTRY YOU WOULD DO THAT TO?
OF COURSE, THEY WON’T TELL YOU
THE TOTAL NUMBER.
THEY WANT YOU TO BELIEVE IT IS
11 MILLION ALWAYS AND FOREVER